Parker the no popcorn was originally
cultivated in Mexico there was this
funeral earned with a sabot a gun that
had a crown that contained pop Colonel
Ramon Salas cameraman make one of the
earliest color television systems and he
patented it in Mexican in the u.s. yeah
modern chewing gum is now made from the
juice of Suburbia trees yes if you
wanted a spread freshener okay the one
with chocolate is believed to be
invented by the Olmecs they used to
crush cocoa beans and then they mix it
with water but the origins of choco also
becomes a larger prey the insta-buck
maker is this technology that they can
bring books super quickly and they don't
have to print thousands oh hey yeah my
tire sweat can you come now
Oh things here in the room
hey hey it's wet you can only promise
hair do you know what rubber dates back
from the times of the Olmecs and the
Aztecs they have this tree that you can
extract latex it's a rubber tree that is
folic acid elastica pretty cool yeah
cool but can you know Lincoln was very
tired
you know that's a lie
yeah Caesar salad yeah generally agreed
that Caesar salad was invented by Caesar
Carlini he had a restaurant in Tijuana
and one dependence they had to improvise
a salad because there was too many
people Wow yeah